so one thing I was wondering about is
what was it like for you guys jumping
into this movie where the lead role had
already been cast did that throw you off
at all or just picturing Brie from day
one make your job even easier than you
would imagine I mean she was absolutely
one of the main draws for us because I
mean we were excited about the idea of
Marvel making the Captain Marvel movie
for sure but it was when brie Larson
that was cast that we could see it and
the humanity that she can bring to it
and just a range of emotion that she can
express and and not wanting to create a
superhero where we're denying that but
where we're really embracing it it was
it was definitely one of the reasons
that we wanted to do the film yeah I was
wondering for you guys what did you find
to be the most surprising part about the
directing process on a Marvel movie well
I think it's for us it's the
collaboration which is not weird at all
because there's two of us and we're
collaborative by nature but it's the
size of the collaboration and on our
other movies we're used to working
really with just the two of us and a
very small group of maybe four or five
other key collaborators on this it's in
the dozens you know if if not the
hundreds because there's just the the
movie is so massive and and at first
that's a challenge but it's also really
a blessing because we're working with
the most talented people in this
business and so they know how to do
things you know better than we could on
our own given all of those new additions
who would you call maybe the unsung hero
of Captain Marvel someone you didn't
even know was gonna be key to you while
making this movie mm-hmm oh my god I
don't think that I could choose just one
person because there are so many I mean
if you when I don't know if you sat
through the whole credits I bet you did
I mean just looking at the number of
people who are involved in the visual
effects for this movie just so many
artists and and so a dozen different
companies so many artists and and not
all of them are even on there I mean
it's just impossible it's
possible to name just one person you
know we worked with editors on our movie
for the first time I've edited all our
other films and just learning what that
collaboration can be like and how much
they can add to it and just having you
know two more brains to work on
something together the our visual
effects supervisor Chris Townsend and
also just such a creative person so
excited to like learn about what we're
thinking and then build off of that and
he's such a wonderful collaborator Ben
Davis who did our cinematography I mean
it's been we're gonna take up all your
time you know but I also like to
celebrate cats so obviously my favorite
parts of the movie but I was curious how
did you come to the decision to name the
cat goose instead of sticking with
Chewie you know it wasn't that wasn't a
big it wasn't a big thing it just felt
like Star Wars was so part of the
culture that it just felt like we wanted
to remove it a little bit you know the
nostalgia for the Star Wars movies which
are there so many of around us you know
when we were when we were kids Star Wars
felt like it was something from the
seventies and eighties and I think that
was the spirit of Chewie from the comics
but we felt like we wanted to sort of
just slide away from that's life yeah
and just like the idea of having a
reference that would have been so
specific to Carol Danvers past as her
past in the movie itself being a pilot
in the 1980s when Top Gun was out and
having a reference that felt a little
bit more specific to her whereas Chewie
when the comics were being written was a
very specific reference in time but now
with like all the movies out it feels
you know more contemporary and not so
specific to her past understandably